[تصفيق]
بينما تستعد قطر المضيفة لظهورها الأول
في نهائيات كأس العالم ، فقد ضمنت
مكانًا في المجموعة A ووجدت نفسها
جنبًا إلى جنب مع بعض أكبر الأسماء
في اللعبة في الوعاء الأول ، فهي ليست
أكبر بكثير من كريستيانو رونالدو و  يغيب ليونيل
ميسي
وفريقهما البرتغال والأرجنتين وكذلك
حامل اللقب فرنسا بلجيكا
وإنجلترا والبرازيل
وإيطاليا بطلة أوروبا
بعد إخفاقه في التأهل
لكأس العالم الثاني على التوالي لكن
هولندا عادت وفريق يبحث عنه الكثيرون.
لتجنب الوعاء الثاني إلى جانب
ألمانيا ، يتطلع أبطال 2014 بشدة
إلى تعويض هذا
الدفاع الكارثي عن لقبهم في
روسيا ، فإن كرواتيا الوصيفة لعام 2018 موجودة
أيضًا في هذا القدر جنبًا إلى جنب مع الدنمارك
مدعومة بعودة كريستيان
إيريكس الذي عاد الأمريكيون مرة أخرى  هذا الجزء الثاني
جنبًا إلى جنب مع مضيفيهم المشاركين في كأس العالم المقبل في
المكسيك ومجموعة المواهب
المكونة من فريق أوروجواي ساديو ماني
وكأس الأمم الأفريقية بطل السنغال.
د الطريق في الوعاء 3 لكنه ليس
المهاجم النجم الوحيد في هذا المهاجم هناك
روبرت ليفاندوفسكي في بولندا صن هيونغ
مين وكوريا الجنوبية جنبًا إلى جنب مع إيران واليابان
صربيا والمغرب وتونس الجزء الرابع
حيث تتعقد الأمور مع
ثلاثة فرق غير معتادة لم يتم تحديدها بعد ولكن
سيظلوا في القرعة إلى جانب
الإكوادور السعودية غانا الكاميرون
والجانب الكندي على قمة موجة
بعد أن تأهلوا لنهائيات كأس العالم لأول مرة
منذ
عام 1986. أماندا ديفيس سي إن إن الدوحة قطر